Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! Thank you everyone
that submitted questions on my Game of Thrones
videos this weekend. Fun fact: I actually found
out that there's like a YouTube limit on the amount
of replies that you can do on a single comment.
Everybody went so crazy after that finale. I
guess YouTube just broke. Thank you everyone
that's been submitting subtitle corrections
too, I'll explain at the end of the video
if you want to do that. If you see like an error
in the subtitles and you want to correct it. It's actually really easy to do. So, here we
go. Just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet. On to questions. Starting
with actually on Twitter actually pulled a
couple questions off of Twitter. Zubair asks,
"Which one would you read first or watch first
if both season six and The Winds of Winter
come out at the same time?" I would actually-
I would probably just read them in the order
that they come out. I don't wait for stuff. Like I just consume media as it's released.
I can understand the desire to hold off on
certain things like it if you wait to watch
something but if I'm gonna make a video about
something and a book will help give context
to that video then I need to read it. Also, I just really don't like waiting for stuff so
there's that too. I'm kind of impatient. Next question: Pinchedgar asks, "Daario was very persistent
on going alone with Jorah. Are you worried he might be jealous and try to get rid of
Jorah?" No, I think there's a certain
camaraderie between them. I mean, they're both kind
of sell swords. They're both really smart
people who are dedicated to Daenerys so if
nothing else then that will bring them together. They want to help her. Jorah probably understands
that he's never going to be with Daenerys,
but he has this love for her that transcends
physical love. He's what you would call a true
believer. That's what his whole speech to Tyrion
whenever their traveling together was about:
-about true faith. So I'm just expecting total bro
road trip. At least one episode of them travelling
together before they find Deanerys. I don't
think it'll be right away. Next question: Thomas
asks, "What is the connection between Dragonglass
and Valyrian steel?" Well, so, Obsidian (that's
what Dragonglass is) that's basically volcanic
rock that has cooled. Valyrian steel is tempered
metal. Surprise, surprise: being that they both
have very similar properties, we're probably
going to find out on the show or in the books
that you forge Valyrian steel by combining it with
obsidian and tempering it with Dragon
fire. That's just an easy slamdunk for both the
books and the show because you have essentially
what is like a Dragonglass factory on Dragonstone.
Stannis said himself on the show it's full
of Dragonglass. Daenerys might feel compelled
to return there at some point on her journey
to Westeros and use it as like a base of
operations when it comes time to fight the
White Walkers. They could turn it into a giant
forge for making more Valyrian steel. The problem
is that nobody in the books that we know
about and nobody on the show knows the connection
between Obsidian and Valyrian steel. One way around that would be for Samwell to find
something when he's at the Citadel. That feels
like an easy thing to give his character. He's
like the character that figures things out
because he reads lots of books, so do not be
surprised if in season seven, you see them
figure out how to make more Valyrian Steel
and start doing that using Daenerys's dragons.
Next question Mariano asks, "What are your
thoughts on where Benjen is is he alive or
dead?" Well, you know George RR Martin leaves it
a lot more open-ended than the show does the
show hasn't mentioned him at all barely so I
think he's still alive and I think he'll
resurface as part of Bran's story and I know alot
of people are wondering if he might be Cold-hands in the books that character hasn't shown
up on the show but it's implied that Cold-hands is much more ancient than Benjen could
be so I don't think that Cold-hands is Benjen,
but yeah he probably is alive and he'll probably
come back with White Walker Intel. I know a lot
of people are wondering if he might be the
Night's King here like he might've been co-opted
by the White Walkers. If that were true, then
they would probably go further to make this
Night's King character look more like Joseph
Molly, look like the actor that plays Benjen,
so I don't think this is Benjen. Next
question Anthony asks, "If Arya wears a new
face, would she be able to see with it? Do you
think that that would persuade her to stop
being Arya and become no one?" No I- I think
that she's always going to be Arya Stark. I
think at some point you regain her sight
but then she'll backtrack again. Jaqen did imply
that all manner of unusual things could happen
when a girl puts on another face. As if he
was trying to say, that Arya trying to use
the face that she used is what made her blind.
But I think there's a magical component to
it that she just doesn't know about yet. Just
wearing the face itself is just just a mask
it it doesn't change anything about her magically
the the magic part is a different technique
that Jaqen just hasn't taught her yet. Next
question, Popcorn asks "The only thing that
went through my head when Ellaria kissed Myrcella
was well she's dead" Well yeah that
could be. Myrcella dying could be the thing that
makes Jamie become a terrible person again
Cersei looks like she backtracked and she's
going to be terrible in season six - the same
thing could happen to Jamie. Like Jamie's time
with Brienne made him want to be a better
person. He tried it, this happens, and erases all the progress he's made, and he just turns
into a terrible person just like Cersei. Thematically, that would kind of fit with what's going on
with Arya like you try to be this new person
but you can never escape the person that you
really are. Next question, Blind Samurai asks,
"you know what they need, Valyrian steel bullets"
that's actually that's an interesting idea
but I think an aerosolized version of Valyrian
steel would work even better like turning into like
a gas bomb - The problem with using projectile
Valyrian steel weapons is that you lose the
Valyrian steel the minute you fire it from a
gun or a bow so it's like a one time only
kind of thing if you have a giant army of
White Walkers and Wights it'd make more sense
to use an area of affect weapon like a giant
gas bomb some of you have asked about wildfire
like is wildfire effective against the White
Walkers? It looks like normal fire isn't because
that White Walker in episode eight walked
right through it without giving it a second thought
they're just there are like a couple weapons on
the show that they've been pointing to as being
very important, Dragon related I think those
will be effective against White Walkers anything
to do with dragons or volcanoes next question,
Remmy asks, "when will Game of Thrones start
shooting, will Winds of Winter be released before
season six?" well game of thrones typically
start shooting sometime around whenever a Comic-con
happens like late June early July that's why
all the actors aren't always able to come
to Comic-con the earliest estimates for Winds of Winter is on or about the time season six
gets ready to come out that's if there aren't
any major delays or George RR Martin doesn't
run into any problems he hasn't made any promises
he hasn't said that that's just people guessing
at how fast he writes and how much material
is left to cover he's not gonna say it's ready
to come out until he submits his final manuscript
for the final material to his editor so when
his editor decides that it doesn't need any
more editing and they can start printing copies
then they'll have a date next question, Xiu
asks, "can you give a prediction on Bran?" well
I think what's going to happen with Bran
is is that he will have information on the
White Walkers that he gets via flashbacks
his story right now is almost exclusive to
what's going on with the War for the Dawn
and there is a lot of other things happening on
the show. So, they weren't quite ready to go that
far that fast they still want to withhold
a lot of that information from the audience
and when you have a character that has that much
power over nature and can see across time
and space it just throws the narrative off
what I'd really like to see is Bran send visions
to the other characters like give Daenerys a vision
of what she needs to do in the way that the
Three-Eyed Raven gave visions to Bran next
question, Airfinch asks, "so has the show caught
up completely with the books now?" no actually
it has not there a lot of things that they
skipped in the books that they might go back
to in season six. There's a lot of people theorizing
that they skipped Lady Stoneheart which actually
happened a while ago in the books so that
when they do it on the show it will be a bigger
WTF so they might give some of the Lady Stoneheart
arc to a different character some of the really
big examples are Euron Greyjoy and the Kingsmoot they skipped that altogether so there
are bits and pieces and details that are are
really important to what's happening in the
War for the Dawn that they just didn't have
time for characters that they had to cut out
that they could always include in slightly
different ways in future seasons and remember
Winds of Winter is going to come out next year
Dan and Dave are going to read that so they can
incorporate some Winds of Winter stuff into
season seven and that's assuming that George
RR Martin hasn't let them read any of his
work prints from Winds of Winter right now like
any unfinished chapters thank you so much
to everyone for so many questions are always
a ton of fun to do and yes I will keep doing
Q&A videos but for those asking which books
to start reading now here are a couple of recommendations
if you haven't read anything yet just start
with the first book by the time you get through
all five books in the next nine months or
so Winds of Winter will be out and season six
will start if you've already read all the
main novels or you don't care about them check
out the side stories you know, just go over to George
RR Martin's author page on Amazon there's
The Rogue Prince, The Princess and the Queen those
two stories comprise the Dance of the Dragon
storyline that Shireen was reading to Ser
Davos in episode nine this October They are
re-releasing the Dunk and Egg trilogy in combined
format like all three books jammed into one
giant book that's all about the early life
of Aegon the fifth, that's where the name Egg
comes from Egg as in Aegon if you haven't
checked it out either World of Ice and Fire
is a lot of fun too, there's a lot more illustrations
in that book its mostly historical it's like
a combination of a bunch of stuff from the
wiki, speaking of books congratulations to
my giveaway winners Anthony Barnes you win
the signed copy of A Feast for Crows and Stalking
Self I love that name you win the Amazon gift
card both of you be sure to message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get your
contact info. My next Game of Thrones bonus
video should post Thursday or Friday that's
going to be an explainer for all the resurrections
that have happened on the show between the
Red God and the Great Other there's just so
much Game of Thrones stuff to get through
that I'm kind of behind my other videos so I'm
trying to catch up on everything this week.
Those of you that want to help out with subtitles
it's really simple if you see an error in
the subtitles just go in through the subtitle menu here you select add captions and
it will take you to this menu where you can edit specific
portions of the existing subtitles so it's
really simple you don't have to make completely
new subtitles. Thank you everyone in advance
if you want to help out with this! (You're welcome Charlie!) In case
you haven't seen it yet I just posted my season
six predictions and you can click here to watch
that and you can click here for my finale
video thank you so much for watching, everybody -
Let's High Five and I'll see you guys tomorrow!